Усіх гостей тут вітають двома мовами.
Це село Холмець неподалік кордону з Угорщиною.
Населення, а тут мешкає тисяча осіб,
60 відсотків – українці та 40 – угорці.
І жодного мовного бар’єру,
принаймні, державну мову тут розуміють геть усі.
І дбають про це розуміння вже в дитячому садочку.
Кожну фразу вихователі повторюють двома мовами.
Відповідно до рекомендацій Міносвіти
для дошкільного виховання у двомовних населених пунктах.
В нас змішані переважно родини. Діти знають і по-українськи, і по-угорськи.
Ці діти вже через 2-3 роки мають піти до школи.
ля угорців на Закарпатті працюють приблизно сто шкіл,
де викладають їхньою рідною мовою.
Але, не виключено, що з наступного навчального року
національним меншинам буде дозволено навчатися рідною мовою
лише до 4-ого класу.
За новим законом про освітуз п’ятого класу
викладання більшості шкільних предметів
має бути виключно українською.
Для спеціалізованих угорських шкіл,
які в Закарпатті працюють ще з 50-х років минулого століття,
це буде означати або закриття,
або повне перепрофілювання у звичайну україномовну школу.
Навіть десь трохи і страшно.
Певно прийдеться міняти статут,
певно прийдеться змінювати назву,
хоча би цього не хотілося. Хотілося би, щоб в Ужгороді зберіглася школа
з угорською мовою навчання.
Переведення шкіл з поглибленим вивченням мов нацменшин
на державну мову, на думку авторів закону,
має допомогти краще знати українську.
В цій школі лише дивуються:
відповідно до рекомендацій Міносвіти тут виділяють
однакову кількість годин
на вивчення угорської мови і літератури та української.
Випускники школи, вважає директорка-угорка,
що викладає українську,
мають добрі результати ЗНО
і взагалі дружать з обома мовами.
Так добре державною
володіють далеко не всі угорці,  особливо в селах,
де їх переважна більшість, та де не в усіх школах взагалі
є вчителі української мови,
каже заступник Закарпатської облради Йосип Борто.
Він сам угорець і переконаний,
що цю давню проблему
новий закон про освіту аж ніяк не вирішує.
Навпаки, лише погіршує ситуацію.
Закарпатська облрада цього року
кілька разів вимагала від Києва
скорегувати 7-му статтю закону.
В 7-мій статті має бути написано те, що написано в Конституції,
те, що є в міжнародних зобов’язаннях України
гарантувати надалі право вивчення рідної мови на всіх рівнях.
Одночасно треба покращити рівень володіння державною мовою
і для цього розробити державну програму.
Батьки учнів угорських шкіл не проти вдосконалення державної мови,
але не за рахунок рідної.
Природознавство, математика…Дитина до 5-ого класу
вивчає всі терміни угорською мовою
в 5ому класі її поставлять перед фактом,
що зараз в тебе все по-українськи. діти не зможуть далі вчитися.
треба українську мову преподавати, як іноземну мову угорцям,
тогда будет інтересно.
Державну мову треба знати
рідну мову теж досконало бажано
і говорити, писати
Сподіваємось, може переглянуть цей закон.
Зараз український закон аналізує Венеціанська комісія.
Україна пообіцяла змінити його
у разі виявлення порушень прав нацменшин.
На це дуже сподіваються у селі Холмець.
Не всі угорці відправляють своїх дітей саме до угорських шкіл,
але усі хочуть, щоб їх не позбавляли права вибору:
де саме їм здобувати освіту.